hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's nach drei monaten endlich
mal wieder ein baby update von alleine
stellen ja was heißt hier schon wieder
das ist glaubt man das dritte update
nein heute geht's richtung dich morath
wenn es um dich gehen so richtig
vorstellen
stimmt jetzt meine ganze zuschauer
scheinlich zu ja wir hatten eigentlich
schon mit acht monaten update gemacht
aber es konnte dann leider doch nicht
hochladen
jedenfalls gibt es heute ein update aber
umso besser ist habe ich nochmal zu
erzählen ja beim letzten mal
also der sprung von monat zu monat 9 ist
wirklich sehr groß
in den letzten monaten hat die ela so
viel gelernt und sie performen auf dem
boden vor mir und ich wollte immer
wissen was kann sie denn schon und was
ist sie und so weiter also momentan hat
selbst das krabbeln angefangen seit etwa
drei wochen
es klappt nicht so komplett am stück
aber sie probiert immer wieder und es
ist sind auch enorme kräfte die daten
damit spielen also die muss ihre arme
bewegen und die beine und sich ganz hoch
drücken und es ist schon faszinierend
daran immer zuzugucken schaffen das
papier
sie ist gerne pop sie versucht es
zumindest
mittlerweile kann sie sich auch alleine
hinsetzen und sitzt dann auch richtig
schön kann man spielen und kommt eben
nicht nur durchs krabbeln vorwärts
sondern auch durch robben also robben
hat sie zuerst gemacht und es macht
jetzt auch bestimmt schon seit fast zwei
monaten also sobald sie sich drehen
konnte von rücken auf dem bauch und vom
bauch auf den rücken hat sie dann kurz
später angefangen
wir nennen sie auch inzwischen arien
robben
das waren leider mittlerweile kann sie
sich auch hoch
die stand dann neulich da habe ich
gerade gedreht also gefilmt und dann
stand sie plötzlich im wohnzimmer hier
wo eigentlich jetzt gerade kamera steht
und hat sich an diesem tisch hochgezogen
und stand dann so vor und ganz wackelig
und deswegen muss man jetzt immer ganz
aufpassen
eben auch die ganzen ecken und kanten
die wir haben wer mir so einen
wohnzimmertisch städtischer dieser
paletten möbel und haben eine glasplatte
drauf also da bist ein bisschen gucken
ansonsten ist unsere wohnung eines
relativ sicher und ich mein also ganz
sicher bekommt man eine wohnung sowie so
nennt man muss halt immer dabei sein und
immer aufpassen habe zum tierschutz geht
nach vorne am eingang das ist ganz
wichtig weil wir dann eine treppe haben
die nach unten geht
und das war einfach viel zu gefährlich
denn die airline steht nicht sehr
schnell besetzt sie dahin dreht sich
kurz weg und plötzlich ist am anderen
ende des zimmers und deswegen tür
schutzgitter bei einer treppe ganz
wichtig ja das ist eine ohne bohren das
heißt er macht sich auch die wände dann
nicht kaputt werden sie einfach nur
eingeklemmt und damit sie passt also die
war ein bisschen zu klein kann man sich
ebenso diese adapter stücke holen und
das passt aber wirklich an jeder tür
wurden hunde was sagen ja ich weiß
damals hatten wir so ein holztisch da
hat er wirklich ganz spitze ecken und da
haben auch anecken schutz draufgehabt
jahres geht das nicht machen zustand zu
gefährlich und so kann man jetzt hat
auch mal die ela einfach durch die
wohnung laufen lassen ohne dass man sie
auf schritt und tritt verfolgen muss ja
ansonsten haben wir bisher keine
sicherung meine backöfen sind ja oben an
meine schränke mit den reinigungsmitteln
konnten sie auch nicht dran weil man die
nicht wie eine normale tür öffnet
sondern weil es ein ganz großer
schubladen sind und die bekommen dass da
gar nicht hin
und ansonsten aber keine woche sie macht
gott ja also doch steckt steckdosen
schutz haben wir denn steckdosen kabel
liegt die kleine ella komisch dass ich
immer alles was war schlecht was
eigentlich verboten ist und ist auch
beim es also immer das was schlecht ist
ungefähr also nee das stimmt ja wo ist
schokolade
bei beliebten spruch warum muss alles
was schon voll schmidt habe ganz treten
sie laden zum ablegen
sie nannten kabel ich glaube irgendwann
elektriker heiraten wahrscheinlich
selber elektriker haben genau diese
laufen am liebsten genau das ist die
lieblingsbeschäftigung von ella kann man
sie an die hand nimmt an beide hände und
damit ihr durch die wohnung läuft das
macht sie meistens mit der hierarchie
aus weil sie aber dann rennt ja also
krabbeln kann sie aufstehen kann sehr
uns sitzen das ist ja schon mal ziemlich
heftig ich glaube sobald sie laufen kann
kann man sich nicht mehr stoppen
ja was wir mittlerweile auch gemacht
haben ist das bett ganz runter
geschraubt und auch das laufgitter ganz
runter geschraubt damit sie eben auch da
drin sein kann und das geschäftsfeld
hatte port jedes kabel weggenommen jeden
fall leichter zu sagen wir sind jetzt
gerade erst seit gestern aus den usa
zurück natürlich haben sich jetzt der
rhythmus und die gewohnheit ein bisschen
geändert weil einfach die zeitumstellung
natürlich auch da war und weil wir
natürlich in den usa nicht den ganzen
tag einfach nur zu hause waren also im
hotel sondern wir war den ganzen tag
immer unterwegs
das heißt die schlafgewohnheiten haben
sich erinnert die essgewohnheiten haben
sich geändert
aber ich hoffe dass ich jetzt alles zu
hause wieder einpendelt und wieder
normalen mv annimmt normalerweise war es
nämlich so dass die ella mittlerweile
jetzt eben auch am tisch mit ist es war
ein ziemlich harter kampf aber da möchte
ich auch ein eigenes video dazu machen
zur beikost einführung denn ich habe
wirklich ganz lange versucht ihr breit
zu geben als karottenbrei gekocht
pastinaken und kartoffeln und alles was
man eben so kochen soll und eben auch
von anfang an so ein bisschen sie daran
gewöhnt und es wollte sie alles gar
nicht und ich dachte einfach die ganze
zivil eben auch noch nicht und habe sie
dann auch wirklich fast acht monate voll
gestillt
und erst kurz bevor ich gesagt habe okay
ich gebe jetzt bald auch mit der beikost
habe ich gemerkt dass sie einfach nur
richtige stücke essen will oder richtig
beim tisch am tisch mit essen will
das heißt alles angefangen mit steak
die liebt ruf steht über alles er bei
jedem stück und dann beißt die da rein
mit dem zwei zähnen die sie schon hat
und dann bleibt meistens noch in dieser
zahnlücke hinaus und hat nur 210
zwischen mittlerweile ist sie wirklich
ganz gut und hat dann mittags eben ihre
normale mahlzeit also diese das
herzhafte das gemüse fleisch mit
kartoffeln oder mit nudeln genau
und dann bekommt sie am nachmittag und
am abend eben noch die option aber wie
gesagt da mache ich auch ein eigenes
beikost wieder weil es schon ein
umfangreicheres thema wenn die mauer
nicht preisgeben andere sachen zu essen
aber habe ich entdeckt dass er meistens
in der windel
das ist ja das gute bei ihr sieht man
dass interview sei was sie gegessen hat
auf jeden fall ja und mache ich das
selber keine kinder also das soll sich
auf keinen fall druck machen
früher hat nun sogar gesagt dass die
kinder dann bereits in zu essen also
richtig zu essen wenn sie selber sitzen
können weil dann einfach die gefahr
nicht besteht dass sie sich verschlucken
weil sobald sie selber sitzen können
sitzen sie eben auch aufrecht und
verschlucken sich nicht so leicht etwas
zu essen und jetzt ist sie zufrieden
genau macht euch dort wo man redet ihr
auch nur mit gleichen zeit gelassen oder
mit freunden
ja auch kinder haben und unter druck
gesetzt
jedes kind lernt anders jedes kind lernt
in seinem eigenen tempo das eine kind
kann schneller krabbeln laufen das
andere kann spieler sprechen das andere
ist besser als es ist komplett anders
wenn man es gerade von sprechen wenn man
auch freunde die haben auch eine tochter
im gleichen alter dies drei wochen
jünger und bei erst zum beispiel mit dem
preis super geklappt also da hat unsere
freundin einfach den brei eingeführt als
die erste mahlzeit an zweiter und die
dritte satz super geklappt
daniela komplettes gegenteil ist gar
kein brei die luisa ist gar keine
stückchen also dass in die kinder
einfach komplett gegensätzlich aber es
klappt jetzt mittlerweile beiden und ja
es ist einfach super und bei jeder messe
pflege sagt anders da gab es sogar eine
studie das ist ganz cool
da haben sie habe zwei kinder gab zwei
identische kinder klinge rollstuhlfahrer
gebracht wie in jungen jahren mit 33
jahren zur rollstuhlfahren bei dem
anderen kind einfach gar nichts dass sie
immer gefördert
das waren richtig angefangen zu turnen
oder alle dran und das amt mit ihnen sei
nichts großes gemacht und im endeffekt
wasser so als dann sechs jahre alt waren
haben beide die gleichen fähigkeiten
gehabt
alles kommt dann wirklich mehr zeit das
kannst dich an trainieren
kein tropfen ja wenn man dabei sind
zurzeit haben wir gewisse schlafprobleme
mit ella weil nach den ersten 2 10 jetzt
auch schon weitere zähne kommen und zwar
haben sich die eckzähne angekündigt und
ich erinnere mich noch zurück an samira
da war es nämlich auch so da waren auf
die eckzähne im sommer hat sich hin
gestimmt jetzt hat sich hingestellt
ich glaube man sieht ja bei samira war
es nämlich so die war als sie die zähne
bekommen hat komplett bund im popbereich
und hat dann überall hautausschlag
bekommen gerade jetzt um den mund herum
war ganz rot überall im gesicht und es
war eben durch diese szene hat auch viel
über die windel rausgelassen also hat er
noch fünf sechs mal am tag eine volle
windel und so ist auch aber die hat
jetzt keine hautprobleme dadurch sondern
meint eben nachts und hat in nachts hat
auch fieber ja also soviel dazu deswegen
schlägt eben auch zurzeit nicht so ganz
gut da muss man sie oft zwischen uns
nehmen beruhigen und so weiter ist total
einfach wie man muss sich vorstellen die
ganze szene die poren sicher dann durch
den kiefer durch und kommt dann hoch
alles ganz natürlich 28 14 32 es ist was
ganz normales aber sowas muss man halt
machen ja ansonsten was haben wir noch
das hat sich mittlerweile ein bisschen
verbessert also sich immer mal besser
mal schlechter
jetzt in den usa war erstaunlicherweise
sehr gut also war gar keine probleme
jetzt immer wieder da jetzt wieder ein
bisschen ausschlag aber wie gesagt es
sich bei ihr immer mal wieder da und mal
wieder weg gab es eigentlich ganz gut
mit den cremes im griff und ansonsten
muss man mal gucken dass sie eben nicht
viel schwitzt und so weiter und ist auch
ein thema da hat wieder hause wo tipps
wie hat es jeder schon abhaken und jeder
sagt man soll das nehmen mal so
hinnehmen
da gibt's 1000 tipps ich bei liebe bis
zu handeln ist aber oftmals weniger mehr
unterwegs waren mit ihrer natürlich
schon viel unterwegs gerade jetzt in den
usa
da war die reise wirklich sehr lange der
hinflug war eigentlich ganz okay dazu
ich ganz gut gefühlt da was mit
empfehlen aber auch noch nicht so
schlimm
und sie hat dann auch echt mehr ganze
zeit lang geschlafen im flieger ist ein
echtes sehr laut es sind sehr viele
menschen da und kinder sind dann einfach
immer anders als der normalerweise sind
es ist einfach ein bisschen unruhiger
aber ansonsten hat es super geklappt sie
war bei unseren shows und unsere mir ja
auch für samira war sehr richtig cool da
hat mir ein monitor vorne bei so
langstreckenflügen und einfach ein
bisschen frozen angeguckt bisschen musik
gehört und hatten auch geschlafen bis
zwei jahre ist liegen normalerweise
kostet normalerweise ja ich glaube man
kann aber an dass sitz buchen wenn man
zum beispiel den autos jetzt mit rein
nimmt und muss dann aber für den sitz
bezahlen ja ansonsten was ich noch für
den tipp habe wenn er unterwegs seid mit
euren kindern vor allem im flieger da
hat mir immer diesem druck auf den ohren
bei start und bei der landung und wenn
ihr den kindern da was zum saugen gibt
als endet eine flasche oder ein
schnuller oder ihr nehmt ihr an die
brust
dann können sie denn trug ebenso
ausgleichen jan jetzt gerade für den
sommer habe ich mv kleidung geholt wie
die kinder
falls jetzt auch mal hier bei dem wetter
raus geht es schon ziemlich warm und vor
allem die sonneneinstrahlung ist nicht
gut was soll er wirklich kinder im
ersten lebensjahr gar nicht der direkten
sonne aussetzen
deswegen habe ich es für die ella sowas
geholt mit langen ärmlichen und auch das
passende höschen dazu so ist er einfach
vor das extra uv kleidung aus dem
badeanzug stoff das heißt sie sich dann
auch nicht warm und schützt sie einfach
vor der sonne und das kann man hier mal
benutzen wenn man rausgeht im schwimmbad
im urlaub das geht wirklich überall
ja und da ist einfach geschützt und auch
gar nicht teuer das hat glaube ich
zusammen sieben oder acht euro gekostet
und ja und natürlich sonnencreme
sonnencreme ohne bitter so ein krieg
ohne ende
ja also eincremen muss muss ich bei dem
wetter immer und auch einfach nicht so
lange in die sonne bei samira habe es
auch schon gemerkt wenn sie zu lange in
der sonne ist dann merkt man auch sofort
an und sie brauchen was die frau was zu
essen es geht ihr da nicht gut deswegen
am besten nie zu lange in die sonne
das gerade erst schlafen ins bett gelegt
und jetzt ja genau weiß eben zum
beispiel die ganze einfach nur müde und
quengelt dann natürlich auch sie will
dann ins bett aber manchmal ist einfach
nicht die schlafenszeit und sie kann
nicht einschlafen und es ist völlig
normal dass kinder auch mal quengeln
oder auch mal weinen und solange man
weiß ja dass kein hunger oder keine
volle windel oder er tut nichts weh ist
es ja auch gar nicht schlimm
und ab und zu hört man sehr dann auch im
video was natürlich völlig normal ist
der trainer auch zu hause und im prinzip
ist die er immer mit dabei und sie kann
er noch nicht sprechen das heißt sie
muss dann weinen und sich auszudrücken
und ganzen kann ich sagen wir drehen
jetzt bist mal kurz ruhig genau das wird
das kind nicht verstehen ja es einfach
es ist normal in unserer umgebung und
jeder der kinder hat weiß auch das kenne
man manchmal auch klingeln beschreibt
das kind immer im hintergrund denn immer
noch immer von morgen ist auch immer ja
das war überhaupt zu benutzen immer ich
meine wir filmen ja auch nicht immer und
ihr seid uns auch nicht immer
genau ja das ist dann mein ab und zu mal
im hintergrund was völlig normal ist es
eh schon nicht alleine ich bin ja da
murat ist ab und zu da ein bisschen ja
immer da ist sie ist ja nicht alleine zu
hause und von daher ist es ganz normal
dass er auch mal meint oder man schreibt
manchmal schweiz auch einfach weil sie
ein löwe sein will
da steht sie dann da und schreiben dann
schreibt er einfach zum beispiel wenn
sie die samira sie auch immer also in
der asse zu bestimmen
wenn man hinguckt dann lacht kinder die
wissen hat echt schon in jungen jahren
und dem anders machen müssen um die
aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen
ja gut ansonsten ist die l wirklich
setzte frieden spielt dann auch einfach
hier im hintergrund oder sirup dann oder
kabel zu mir nach vorne sitzt dann bei
mir also wie gesagt ihr hört sie auch
ihr seht ihr nicht und die sanierung
sich das ist so eine tolle schwester
eine richtig vorbildliche schwester als
sie versucht dann auch manchmal so die
mama rolle einzunehmen und trägt sie
dann herum muss man sich auch immer
aufpassen weil ich dann immer sagt
'mensch samira pass auf nicht dass du
stoll passt weil sie hat ja nicht den
reflex wie wir also ich würde ja wenn
ich stolpere und elf mal würde ich ja
noch festgehalten
bei sanierer denke ich würde sie
loslassen weil sie einfach sich selber
stützen würde
die hatte er da noch nicht so drin und
muss man aufpassen ansonsten sie da wir
dann auch mal was zu essen geben oder
auch die trinkflasche und sie spielt
echt super mit er also das ist wirklich
wirklich sehr schön
die große schwester ist ja eine
verantwortung gegenüber ihrer schwester
momentan wie alt diese war wirklich
wahnsinn da sind richtig stolz brauchen
echt schön
manchmal ist es immer einfach zusammen
41 zimmer und da ist auch so schön bunt
und das gefällt ihr echt richtig gut hat
es viel zu entdecken eine tolle große
schwester irgendwann sieht sie das video
in nächste bestimmt auch stolz drauf
ich meine klar kann jetzt am iran nicht
alleine lassen also das auf keinen fall
wir übergeben jetzt hat die
verantwortung aber natürlich sind wir
als sie lassen noch papa lass das stimme
oder den papa mit trainer ja da ich sie
jetzt noch unversucht einzuschlafen
jedenfalls glaube ich dass wir jetzt so
ziemlich alle themen angesprochen haben
die wir ansprechen wollten jetzt noch
bei christie co
genau das mache ich auf jeden fall noch
dass ihr da auch ein paar tipps
natürlich auch bekommt und eben auch
genau sieht wie ich das mache was ich
mache was es zu essen gibt und wie das
eben alles so klappt ansonsten denke ich
im falls ihr noch fragen habt und
schreibt sie uns einfach in die
kommentare dann würden wir sie beim
nächsten baby update einfach beantworten
und ich hoffe dass ich das video
gefallen hat und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal wieder bis es dann mal was
gemacht